hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and this is just
crazy we just saw a massive Quirk
Awakening that clearly foreshadows the
future of Deku and one for all a fiery
clash between Brothers has come to an
end in an epic way and things are
getting more and more intense in this
final Arc before we get into it quick
thank you to Nino Kuni crossworlds for
sponsoring this video have you ever
wanted to live inside a Studio Ghibli
movie I freaking love Ghibli on a
spiritual level so when I heard that net
marble is coming out with a new
immersive Studio Ghibli RPG I was hooked
instantly the game is called ninokuni
crossworlds it is absolutely stunning it
features music by the legendary Joel
hisaishi and I just can't wait to play
this game choose from five different
characters each wielding their own
unique weapons and enter a magnificent
fantasy world full of beauty action and
adventure this is an absolutely massive
release and it's available for
pre-registration right now just click
the top link down in the description
Nino Cooney crossworld is available on
mobile and PC and it literally has
everything that I could ever want in a
game they even allow players to join
together and create and expand their own
kingdoms they can compete with other
Kingdoms in various PVP modes and they
can then fight for the title of the best
Kingdom on the server against rival
kingdoms honestly this is so cool you're
gonna love this game so pre-register
right now Link in the description
finally this video will contain Boku no
hero manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned so in
the previous chapter horikoshi went out
of his way to emphasize the importance
of a flash fire fist as the strongest
known Fire based move the previous few
chapters also establish the fact that
Dobby is totally out of control he is
going berserk and threatening to burn
down entire city blocks because of this
Shoto knows that he must stop his
brother now and he knows that he has to
be the one to do it no one else can
solve this problem for him he has to
step up and take responsibility for his
villain brother and directly related to
that the latest chapter starts off with
a flashback to just before the class 1a
students headed out to fight the
villains at this point Deku is worried
about Shoto because Shoto has decided
that he will be the one to take down
Dobby and since Dobby is shoto's brother
there is a real possibility that Shoto
won't be able to bring himself to hurt
him if this were to happen if Shoto were
to break down emotionally or decide to
take it easy on Dobby then he and many
others could end up losing their lives
this is a massive burden that Shoto has
taken upon his own shoulders and Deku is
Justified viably concerned but Shoto
tells Deku not to worry about him
because this is his fight and he cannot
run away from it Dobby is a product of
his family's sins and even though
Endeavor is the one who is most
responsible for what happened to Dhabi
Endeavor is not the best person to fight
him first of all endeavor's guilt could
become a huge distraction for him and
lead to his defeat and second of all
Dobby's Flames are stronger than
Endeavors and with Dobby willing to go
all out and Destroy his own body in the
process Endeavor could be killed in a
potential fight to the death with Dobby
which would be a terrible blow for the
heroes and I mean this both in terms of
Manpower and in terms of morale we have
to remember that endeavor is still the
number one Pro Hero and that position
has a lot of symbolic value if the
number one Pro Hero were to be killed
the public would Panic even harder than
they have been panicking up to this
point and the heroes would lose all
faith in their ability to actually win
the War furthermore because of the
unique nature of his Quirk Shoto has a
trick up his sleeve that Endeavors
simply doesn't possess and could never
possess Shoto has a brand new ability
that he has been perfecting an ability
which could prove to be crucial for
ultimately defeating Dobby's
unbelievably powerful flames this is
shoto's ultimate move that he has been
working on for quite a while and as a
fiery ax appears on shoto's chest Deku
comments that it kind of looks like
Flashfire fists so the most powerful
fire move but there is something
different about it Shoto had been
working on this move while Deku was out
being a vigilante so Deku wasn't there
to witness the process but he soon gets
a first-hand demonstration of what makes
this move so special despite the fact
that a fiery X has appeared on shoto's
chest kaminari is able to poke the flame
directly because it's not hot at all the
secret to this ultimate move is using
both sides of shoto's Quirk at the same
time he is using the flame side of his
Quirk and the ice side of his quirk in
one single move but he's not just using
Fire and Ice separately like oh he's
throwing ice and fire at his opponent at
the same time so it's considered one
move no Shoto seems to be learn
literally combining the properties of
Fire and Ice into one entity now I'm not
a rocket surgeon so I don't really
understand science that well but if I
understood correctly Shoto uses his
heart as the Center focus and he then
circulates both cold and warm blood from
his heart throughout the rest of his
body this creates a total thermal
equilibrium and he can then manifest
this fiery ax that isn't even hot
meaning that it's something like cold
fire it's ice that behaves like a flame
its ice and Flame at the same time Shoto
is no longer just using the ice side of
his Quirk to cool his body down enough
for him to use the Fireside effectively
his ice and fire are effectively
becoming one single entity a new entity
and this is why Shoto has to be the one
to fight Dobby no one else has the
ability to counter Dobby's impossibly
hot blue flames with what is essentially
flaming ice
despite the serious emotional baggage
that comes with it no one is better
suited to take Dobby down than Shoto
himself back on the battlefield in the
present Shoto and Dabi are still going
all out and it looks like the entire
city is about to go up in Flames as a
result of their fiery Clash at this
moment Shoto is using the ice side of
his Quirk to try to cool down Dobby and
his flames and also to try to minimize
the damage that Dobby is doing to their
surroundings Dobby acknowledges that
Shoto is definitely the right man to
take him on the ice side of shoto's
Quirk allows him to withstand Dobby's
brutal fiery attacks and his ice side
can also negate and quench Dobby's
massive wall of fire which is consuming
everything in sight Dobby is impressed
by shoto's determination and his sense
of moral conviction but morality is
certainly not something that Dobby cares
about and in that sense the two brothers
could not be more different we then see
Dobby assuming a truly terrifying form
in this moment he really looks like a
monster like something completely
inhuman this is why I've been saying
that Dobby must be some sort of nomu
human hybrid Not only was he healed from
his injuries using the same type of
procedure that was used to create the
nomu but his behavior and energy have
become truly monstrous in these last few
chapters horikoshi is clearly signaling
that Dobby has abandoned all shreds of
his humanity and that he has become
something other than human Dobby then
launches a massive fiery attack into the
ground and this destroys the surface
beneath them in a horrible scorching
Inferno but Vernon and the other
Sidekicks intervene to help Shoto
withstand the Flames even though they
end up taking a lot of damage themselves
as a result of their intervention
burning definitely looks injured at this
point and my wife who is in danger
senses started going off like crazy
during this chapter but there isn't much
time to to dwell on that because the
brutal clash between the two brothers
continues so I'm just gonna say
horikoshi please don't burn us again
anyway Shoto remembers his past and how
lonely he had been as a result of his
family history and as a result of
endeavor's behavior he felt like
everyone else was far ahead of him
socially they knew how to communicate
and open up and be friends with each
other while Shoto had to learn all of
these things from scratch when he
finally entered the UA we gotta remember
that he spent his entire life
essentially isolated from people and
training with his father all the time
and this made him feel lonely and
insecure thankfully his classmates from
1A didn't judge him or reject him for
being so withdrawn instead every single
one of them was there for him and they
gave him a place where he could be safe
and where he could overcome his
childhood trauma and when he says all of
them he also means minata so the minata
haters just have to deal with it so with
this in mind a fierce Shoto launch as
his ultimate move the move that will
show everyone what he is really capable
of Shoto launches A Massive Attack
called The Great Arctic tsunami which to
me looks like an ice cold Firestorm I
really don't know how else to describe
it as he unleashes this tremendous
attack at Point Blank Range Shoto tells
Dobby that he can still turn back even
if he has to be forced to do it finally
he asks Dobby to please just stop all of
this as the attack connects we see
glimpses of both Dobby and shoto's faces
back when they were kids before
everything went horribly wrong and then
in the final panel of the chapter we see
that shoto's icy Firestorm attack has
seemingly Frozen the entire city block
around them Dobby looks like he may have
just been defeated and even the text on
the final page declares that Shoto has
just surpassed his limits and that he
has finally quelled his brother's flames
and that is how this crazy chapter ends
but does this really mean that Dobby has
been defeated the chapter certainly
seems to imply that this is the case
especially with that text on the final
page and of course we got all of that
built up about shoto's ultimate move and
then the Epic way that he Unleashed that
move also seems to suggest that he just
won the fight but horikoshi could flip
the script on us again so we can't save
for sure Dobby is no longer a normal
human who will just go down when a
normal human is supposed to go down
Dobby is truly a monster now that much
has been made clear so who knows what he
is actually capable of the big question
is this will Dobby die after pushing his
own body way too far or do the events of
this chapter imply that he has been
defeated and injured but not killed
before this chapter I was leaning
towards the possible ability of Dobby
actually dying because his insane mental
state and self-destructive actions
seemed like a pretty big death flag but
the conclusion of this chapter makes me
question whether this is really the end
for him even as he Unleashed his
ultimate attack upon Dobby Shoto was
still begging his brother to just stop
all of this so Shoto could still be
hoping that Dobby will see the error of
his ways and repent with that in mind
Shoto may have held back against Dobby
and that could prove to be a terrible
mistake if Dobby survives and then
continues to hurt people in the future
let me know what you guys think what
will happen next will Dobby die will he
survive but just be extremely injured
and therefore defeated at least for now
or will he somehow find a way to
continue fighting did Shoto hold back
against his brother in the hopes that
Dobby can still change if so will Shoto
come to regret this decision be sure to
let me know what you think down in the
comments below also what did you think
about shoto's ultimate move which
somehow combines the properties of Fire
and Ice on a molecular level he seems to
be creating a completely different
entity something that doesn't appear in
nature something like ice fire or fiery
ice or whatever you want to call it
finally could this crazy ultimate move
by Shoto hint at deku's ultimate Quirk
Awakening if Shoto can seemingly combine
the two sides of his Quirk on a
molecular level to create something
entirely new something that doesn't even
exist in nature then could Deku do
something similar by combining all of
the different Quirk factors within one
for all into a single entity will Deku
also learn to unite all the different
quirks within him into a single Quirk
that defies the laws of nature and
becomes the Ultimate Weapon that would
be a true one for all quirk Awakening
and it would completely change the game
in mha this development with Shoto and
his ultimate move could be a lot more
important to the story than we realize
right now so we have to pay close
attention to what happened next if you
guys enjoyed this video and you want to
see more mha content in the future leave
a quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps me out a lot and of
course if you're new to anime outpro or
maybe watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime offroar
thanks again to ninokuni crossworlds for
sponsoring this video check it out Link
in the description as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya Space Cowboys